i'm very disappointed about it i don't
think that
i mean i i've i've apologized about this
thing
what happened
at least 100 times or so
thomas markle is speaking out following
his daughter
meghan markle and prince harry's
tell-all interview with oprah winfrey
the last time we spoke i was laying in a
hospital bed
the queen was very concerned about the
whole situation with thomas markle
she was worried about megan and the
impact it was having on her in the
lead-up to the wedding
megan's 76 year old father appeared on
tuesday's good morning britain
and weighed in on the duchess of
sussex's claim that there were
conversations
and concerns in the royal family about
how dark her son archie's skin color
would be
when he was born in may 2019 i have
great respect
for the royals and i don't think the
british
royal family are
racist at all i don't think the british
are racist
i think los angeles is racist california
is racist but
i don't think the brits are and that's
not all he had to say on the subject
the thing about what color will the baby
be or how dark will the baby be
i'm guessing and hoping it's just a dumb
question from somebody
it could just be that simple it could be
somebody
asked a stupid question
rather than being a total racist
thomas's comments come
after megan spoke candidly to oprah
about her fallout with her dad ahead of
her i do's to harry in may 2018.
their relationship fell apart after
thomas decided to work with the tabloids
leading up to their royal wedding i've
lost
there's a lot that's been lost already
and i grieve a lot i mean i've lost my
father i lost a baby
i nearly lost my name i mean there's the
loss of identity
but i'm still standing she didn't lose
me
i would have always been there before i
i'm on the airport now she wants me
in a bonus clip from sunday's interview
which aired on cbs this morning monday
megan opened up about the moment she
confronted her father
and asked if he was working with the
tabloids
we called my dad and i asked him and he
said
no absolutely not i said you know the
the institution has never intervened for
anything for us
but they can try to go in and kill this
story
but if they do this once we're not going
to be able to use that same leverage to
protect our own kids one day
if you tell me the truth we can help
and he wasn't able to do that in
addition to the privacy
um and copyright um infringement that
megan is suing the mail on sunday for
she also filed subsequent claims against
the mail on sunday that they
had actively contributed to the
breakdown of her relationship
with her father thomas ultimately missed
his daughter's wedding after
suffering a heart attack and on tuesday
he recalled the phone conversation he
had with his then soon-to-be son-in-law
harry harry had said to me at that point
if you had listened to me this wouldn't
have happened to you
and
me laying in a hospital bed after i've
had a procedure
and getting a stint put here and this
didn't put here
felt that that was kind of snotty so i
hung up on him
that was the last time thomas says he
spoke to his daughter
and he also took this jab at his now
son-in-law
referencing an infamous nude pic of
harry taken in las vegas in 2012
and the time he was photographed wearing
a nazi uniform in 2005.
we all make mistakes i also said
we all make mistakes but i've never
played naked pool
and i've never dressed up like a hitler
in many ways
thomas markle has kind of shot himself
in the foot because he's gone on
national television to try and make
amends
and then in the same interview he goes
and puts the boot into prince harry
now thomas says he just wants to hear
from his daughter
bottom line is i've never heard back
from megan or harry in any way shape or
form
i would love to hear from